realmente hay presión de eeuu hacia
colombia para que se respeten los
derechos humanos en el país como lo han
pedido varias ong
pues hubiéramos querido que la presión
no fuera más efectiva
y enfocada a los asuntos que están
afectando la situación humanitaria
nos alegra que en esta visita se haya
hecho énfasis en algunos temas pero en
general creemos que la comunidad
internacional puede tener un papel mucho
más activo
para frenar la crisis humanitaria que ha
provocado este gobierno con la parálisis
del acuerdo de paz y con la represión
violenta a la protesta social y la nula
voluntad para avanzar en garantías de
los derechos humanos señor jefe el
presidente dijo y lo voy a citar
textualmente cero tolerancia con
cualquier conducta de algún miembro de
la fuerza pública en lo que tiene que
ver con derechos humanos recordemos que
su organización denunció a 39 muertos en
las protestas durante el paro nacional y
la gran mayoría fueron realizados por o
fueron perpetrados por policías esta
política de 'cero tolerancia' si se está
llevando a cabo
de ninguna manera lo que encontramos es
que no solamente la policía nacional con
asistencia también de los militares ha
llevado a cabo una feroz y violenta
represión de los ciudadanos que reclaman
sus derechos en una situación de hambre
y crisis social muy aguda especialmente
contra los jóvenes sino que también en
las regiones se nota que la fuerza
militares no están cumpliendo su papel
de llevar seguridad a las regiones donde
antes estaba las farc y por el contrario
han favorecido la expansión y el
copamiento de sus territorios por parte
de grupos paramilitares con los cuales
hay una activa connivencia ya los cuales
no combate el compromiso del gobierno
era combatir y es mantener estos grupos
paramilitares para brindar seguridad en
estas regiones y son estos grupos
básicamente los mayores responsables de
las del incremento de las masacres y de
los asesinatos de los líderes sociales
señor yepes y pueda que después de esta
visita de blinken se produzca un cambio
de política para proteger los derechos
humanos por parte del gobierno
colombiano
esperemos que así sea pero creo que hace
falta que se cumplan también algunas
recomendaciones que por ejemplo la
cámara representantes de eeuu ha
planteado en el sentido de no favorecer
a ayuda militar para la represión de la
protesta social y que no se entreguen
recursos para las fumigaciones o la
erradicación forzada de cultivos esto
favorecería a avanzar en el cumplimiento
de los acuerdos de paz y favorecería a
la posibilidad de la libre expresión de
la ciudadanía por revertir esta crisis
humanitaria y esta violación masiva de
derechos humanos que ha impuesto el
gobierno de iván duque